why don't we go to trey from seattle
trey from seattle you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can hey
david i was just wondering what do you
think
the future of the republican party is
too soon to know too soon to know i
think that you know uh
so what we see right now is a power
struggle donald trump at his cpac speech
saying here's a list of republicans that
are bad and that i'm going to try to
defeat
and you can donate to me i will be the
king maker in 2022.
on the other hand you have some
republicans who remain behind donald
trump others who want the republican
party to get out from trump
you have a legal battle right now where
the republican party is saying
we can use trump's name and likeness to
fundraise whereas trump is saying
stop using my name people should donate
to me and i'll decide
who is going to win in the republican
party we just have to wait and see in
2022
who wins and who loses do marjorie
taylor greene and lauren beaubert and
madison cothran get reelected
or do they get humiliated and made
one-term
trumpian uh radicals i just think we
don't know yet what the future of the
party is
interesting yeah i i've done a lot of
research
onto kind of the evolution of the
republican party
and yeah i found it that it's almost as
if each generation has tried to out
conservative
uh the other um but not trump i mean
trump's thing oh until trump yeah right
because because trump ran on a whole
different paradigm which was just kind
of shock value and
faux populism right yeah it went from
you know richard nixon
epa like you said i believe a 1.2
you know cueing on crazies like
marjorie taylor green right but in the
middle of that in the middle there's no
there's important stuff in the middle
which was reaganomics and then
the radicalization of newt gingrich and
then the sort of
dim-witted george w bush and then the
racism inspired by obama and that all
culminated in trump
right yeah and uh my last question for
you
is uh about the green new deal sure
what do you think we could do to
modify it or make it less radical which
parts are radical
what's that which parts are radical
well forgive me i haven't read the
entire bill
so is there any of it that you can point
to that's radical
uh 100 relying 100
on renewable energy by what date
uh what i'm sorry well that's only
radical if we say that it's going to be
by three years from now right like
eventually it wouldn't be radical to say
at some point we should get to that
it becomes a question of when is it
reasonable right
yeah um i hoped i hope that the bill is
meaning that
this is going to be a more smooth
transition towards that and i want that
to happen
yeah and not so abruptly um
it can't happen abruptly because we
don't have the supply you know anybody
who's scared that abruptly
we're going to have to be only be
depending on wind we we don't have the
supply by definition it will have to be
a you know a a relatively long
transition
right right well thank you very much
david
no problem yeah but so find the parts
that you find to be radical and then
let's talk again
oh yes yes all right all right trey from
seattle very good yeah i mean if you if
you're gonna say it's um
if you're gonna say it's radical you've
got to tell me what is radical
and uh yeah one of our sponsors is
vincero
watches giving you 15 percent off a high
quality wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on
you can often see me wearing my ventura
watch on the show
mine is the gunmetal vessel model i'm a
big fan of the metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at
fair prices which is why they have over
twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman